the people of Northwest Syria have
suffered a lot during 12 years of Civil
War their Health Care system which
barely survived their strikes in
artillery bombardment is on the brink of
collapse many here need medical help and
fear what little support they have may
not be available for much longer
I take my cancer dose here on a regular
basis as I'm receiving Medical Care here
for free this is my fifth free dose and
just imagining what might happen to
thousands of those who are receiving
treatment here and it might stop scares
me it costs thousands of dollars to get
treated and people can afford even the
cost of living
the potential closure of the bubble hour
Crossing with turkey would cut off viral
humanitarian Aid to thousands in
desperate need
our Hospital provides many free
healthcare services for thousands in the
area we receive around 200 patients per
day and the numbers are increasing as
the U.N fund is gradually decreasing to
the area in short those who come to get
these services are the most vulnerable
people people will literally lose their
lives if they did not receive proper
Medical Care especially since the area
is still going through the wall
yeah
to add to the problem two powerful
earthquakes in February damaged or
destroyed at least 55 medical facilities
despite the challenges medical staff
here are determined to continue their
work they're also appealing for help it
is not clear how the International
Community will react if the border is
permanently closed but the loss of the
lifeline will have an immediate impact
for many here the attempts by this year
in government to control crossword
delivery is alarming many including the
U.N security Council human rights
activist and medical workers Babel Hawa
is a crucial Lifeline for opposition
held areas in the Northwest they have
suffered 12 years of Civil War and need
the border to remain open so
humanitarian supplies continue to arrive
atlib Northern Syria